I received a video from a concerned
citizen one of our viewers in Dothan I
think it's pronounced Dothan maybe
Dothan Alabama
um Marjorie Taylor green was in Alabama
about 10 days ago
at an event at which filming was not
allowed but our viewer this concerned
citizen
surreptitiously filmed and in this event
sponsored by the Alabama Federation of
Republican women uh Marjorie Taylor
green was the keynote speaker she
suggests shooting vaccinators if indeed
people start coming door-to-door
offering vaccines this is a sitting
member of Congress this is video
provided exclusively to us take a look
at this take a listen to this and one
more thing on that you lucky people here
in Alabama might get a knock on your
door because I hear Alabama might be one
of the most unvaccinated states in the
nation
guys they're cheering for being
unvaccinated they're cheering for being
unvaccinated they're cheering because
they haven't been vaccinated
well Joe Biden wants to come talk to you
guys
he's going to be sending one of his
police state friends uh to your front
door we I call them nurses you know
police state friends I I would call them
nurses
door take down your name your address
your family members names your phone
numbers your cell phone numbers probably
ask for your social security number and
whether you've taken the vaccine or not
yeah well what they don't know is in the
South we all love our second amendment
rights
can you imagine
[Applause]
you're showing up on our front door are
we
we're big on our Second Amendment rights
and we're not big on Strangers showing
up at our front door this is a sitting
member of Congress joking about the idea
Joe I mean is it a joke I guess is the
question alluding to the idea of if
people come around offering vaccines to
keep us safe to reduce the chance that
we die
um guns would be what are deployed
against those individuals a sitting
member of Congress so thanks to our
viewer who is asked to remain anonymous
who filmed this surreptitiously again
that was July 23rd in Dothan Alabama
um it was an event actually
uh that Mo Brooks also was there Mo
Brooks is the guy who despite saying
that the January 6th Insurrection was no
big deal we found out he was wearing
body armor that day he also spoke at
this event and absolutely horrifying
spread the video far and wide we do want
to make sure as many people as possible
see that one of our sponsors is geology
the place to go for men's skin care
geology helps men find a simple skincare
routine that works it's personalized for
you by a dermatologist and geology can
help with dark puffy eyes acne oily skin
protecting your skin against damage you
answer a few questions about your skin a
dermatologist will design a personalized
skin regimen for your needs you'll get a
30-day trial with the products they
recommend to try them out if you like
how it goes they'll keep sending it to
you these aren't bogus Miracle creams
these are just the clinical
evidence-based products that
dermatologists have at their disposal
but they're tailored personally to you
based on the products you really need I
took the quiz a couple of months ago
their dermatologists matched me with a
regimen that's just great for me I've
been happy with the results my Skin's
looking great I can actually see a
difference go and take geology's free
quiz and when you use my link right
underneath this video you will save up
to 40 percent off your first paid month